tying three for points in an All-Star
Game Tatum been doing it this entire
second half 10 for 18.
18 from Beyond The Arc
the reason why he's one of the Front
Runners for that MVP of the regular
season
started off the season high too
[Music]
as did the Celtics the 25 start
NBA back in Action Thursday we got a
doubleheader for you on TNT Grizzlies
and Sixers Warriors and Lakers ESPN back
at it Friday with the Heat and the bucks
at Milwaukee and the Thunder and the
Suns so no one got the approval that
should have been Matt McCoy's photo
instead of Joanne
there's the record now held on listen
LeBron looks real strong
[Music]
Tatum
don't sit down Jason Tatum look it up
front for embiid Mitchell and seal
defense Mark that down Candace versus
defensive moment of the day
was that a message was that a message
ready in Salt Lake City anything you can
do
all right you got DeRozan I'll hit him
Tatum fired
Jason Taylor hey uh Reggie you know what
we call that for the king we call that a
business Luca we've been talking a lot
about
world where you got to play a little
defense here
nobody yeah
[Applause]
that's a matchup they're going at one
another right Anthony Edwards on the
floor on team LeBron the Aaron Fox Brown
there goes somehow save that love and by
ATT 5G fast and reliable
well Tatum's on the floor Brown is on
the bench team yadas will take for the
second quarter
[Applause]
potato maybe has his sights set on that
MVP award that was Candace's call two
days ago called George in the quarter
so yesterday the HBCU game Donovan
Mitchell gave the entire Grambling
basketball team a pair of shoes
gets into the end call George making a
case for himself
[Music]
since this quarter began
see the honest and the red and yellow
Tina Brown and the blue
and neither of the captains would play
as Tatum buries another triple
finding Tatum all eyes on him
listen he thought about it he thought
about it
a shooting Clinic out here 48-ft this
one half court
[Applause]
potato may rare Miss
and an offensive rebound sets up to be
honest once again so they're pushing
this lead to 12 here
[Music]
[Applause]
twice Timmy honest has one quarters
donations to raise the future of ice
here's the alley from sabonis
oop finish by Tatum
[Music]
yeah checks in here
go ahead Jason